rights of the children of French jihadis
have appealed to the UN for the children
to be allowed back to France they're
currently being held in camps in Syrian
Kurdistan one of the lawyers who helped
who lodged the complaint says the
children would be able to adapt to a
normal life in France when the French
people every day for three years in a
row are being told that this children
are time bombs they want to prove their
pet raishin but in fact they're being
the seen 84 children already returned to
France they have depth it they're being
socialized they're okay according to the
Save the Children charity there are now
more than two and a half thousand
children in camps in northern Syria and
from around 30 countries Mary dose the
lawyer we just heard from things around
a hundred of them are French France is
currently dealing with the return of
these children on a case-by-case basis
the majority of French people seem to be
against the children's return a new poll
found that 67% of respondents didn't
want them in France we spoke to Patrick
Jardin the father of one of the victims
of a Paris concert-hall attack carried
out by ISIL
he thinks of children of jihadis have to
pay the consequences of their parents
actions parents are bearing
responsibility for the future of their
children they've left France voluntarily
nobody forced them out they've decided
to fight against France they've crossed
themselves out of France and
unfortunately their children should
account for the consequences for me
these children coming back is out of the
question I don't even consider them
French nationals
our sister channel RT Fran spoke to
paris residents to see what they thought
about the children's fate children
should be protected under all
circumstances
it creates real threat lighting this
children back they have to be honorary
educated it's risky these are children
since when are children danger all they
need is good environment they will
flourish
you